before all of that some big news
expected today concerning coronavirus
jabs and young people the government's
expected to green light advice from
vaccine experts to offer the jab to
healthy teenagers aged 16 and over with
the university's minister telling us in
the last hour an update is imminent
its expected approval will be given to
advice from the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation which says
healthy teenagers over 16 should be
offered the jab the chance rather to get
a jab currently 17 year olds within
three months of their 18th birthday can
get their first kovi jab after that the
only under 18s who should have been
offered a vaccine are young people aged
12 to 17 with certain underlying health
conditions or who live with an at-risk
adult but there's still a way to go to
get jabs into the arms of young people
who are already eligible analysis from
sky's data and forensics team last week
found that two in five people aged 18 to
29 in england still hadn't had their
first jab in the last hour we spoke to
the university's minister michelle
donalon she was reluctant to preempt the
decision but i pushed her as you would
expect on whether she was at least
curious about what might be announced
i am curious but i don't think my
speculation will give anybody any
clarity we should all wait for that um
policy announcement um following jvci's
uh update on their advice
i also christmas donald on whether the
government will consider introducing
cash incentives to encourage young
people to get jabbed
i think the biggest way that we can get
young people to be vaccinated is to
promote the benefits of vaccination
and we've got some fantastic role models
from across different sectors including
sport and culture that have come out
and really has emphasized those benefits
of getting vaccinated but we'll keep
everything on the table and review all
options for incentivizing uh everybody
to get the vaccine
let's speak to luke pollard he's the
shadow environment secretary hello to
you thanks for joining us uh this
morning mr pollard um cash for jabs what
do you think
well if it helps uh with the increase of
role of rollout of the vaccine for young
people that's a great idea i think we
should try a whole range of things but i
think the best way to get more young
people to take the job is to have uh
that message communicated by other young
people to young people because what we
want to achieve is that last cohort that
30 or so of young people who haven't yet
come forward to feel that they should to
be encouraged to do so to understand the
benefits of the vaccine for themselves
and their families and i think the best
way to communicate that is not
necessarily to have ministers standing
behind a podium tell them that is to
have people they trust they look to
people from their own age range to be
able to make that case for them
certainly i think that would be more
powerful than anything myself or a
minister can say to encourage that final
take-up of those young people
oh i don't know money talks doesn't it
what sort of amount do you think might
swing them
well i mean the difficulty here is that
i'm a 41 year old bloke i don't i'm not
a young person in the target cohort so
what i want to see is is actually those
young people come forward and actually
say what incentives what uh what
encouragement would be most useful and i
think you know being able to communicate
what the challenges are to those uh
young people by other young people i
think is the right way of of
communicating this message bear in mind
that these are the same young people
who've been subject to the exam chaos
over the last year uh that are subject
to the uncertainty that sometimes get
blamed by government ministers for doing
what they've been encouraged to do going
out enjoying themselves when
restrictions lift and then get blamed
for a spread in the virus so clear
consistent messaging being shared by
people they trust often people in their
own age ranges i think the use of
celebrities and people that people look
up to role models are a good way of
doing it but we need to try all these
different measures all these different
approaches to to ensure that everybody
uh takes up the job and i think the best
way of doing that is through powerful
consistent clear messages communicated
by people they trust and that should be
the case where that is a yeah aiming at
an 80 year old person or someone who's
uh 16 17 18 you've got to find the right
message to get there yeah i'm not always
convinced that ministers are that might
mention a word in edgeways here it would
it's the younger people that we need to
uh convince 30 of them up to the age of
30 still not been vaccinated joe biden
thinks a hundred dollars should do it
for people in the u.s do you think
that's a reasonable amount here in the
uk hundred pounds or so
well i i want to see what the evidence
is to see where that would work but i
mean from my point of view getting
everyone double jabs is the national
mission we need to support labour
supports that effort nationally but i
want to see what is most effective and i
think the best way of doing that is
instead of getting a load of politicians
in a room to work out what is the right
solution for their point of view let's
get young people let's get them to be
the communicators let's get them to
design that incentive system because
then it will be more effective because
ultimately if we're using public money
to encourage
any type of vaccine take up i want that
money to be well spent and that means
having it to be as uh on message as on
target as
as as useful as it possibly can be but i
think the vast majority of young people
have already taken up uh their vaccine
they are the best people to communicate
what was the experience how did it uh
how to make them feel how does that
change their interaction especially
people thank you okay you've said all of
that to me once already thanks very much
we only have a limited amount of time as
you know it's a lot cheaper giving kids
hundred quid than uh what it costs to
put people in icu i'm guessing let me
ask you about um vaccinating 16 and 17
year olds good idea
well it's been carried out right around
the world at the moment in a safe way
and if this uh increases the resilience
of our nation and reduces the number of
people uh facing hospitalization or
facing long covid then i think it is a
good idea um but i would like to see as
well as us vaccinating people at home is
making sure we're putting the same
effort uh into ensuring that
vaccinations are taking place around the
world because in the middle of a global
pandemic there's something that sits
ever so slightly and easily with me as
we're vaccinating some people who are
lower risk in the country where there's
still higher risk people internationally
who haven't got that the answer in
politics as is always the case here is
and rather than or so we need to do all
those things at the same time but i
think we should be encouraging young
people to take up the job it shows that
it's working in europe and america in
particular and we need to build on that
success so we can get out of this
horrible pandemic we find ourselves